To
the infrastructure
sector,
that's our greatest need.
We plan to invest and this is a
conservative estimate,
$300,000,000,000 in the next few years
into infrastructure.
This will go into roads and airports,
into the railways,
into ports,
and I would say to anybody going into
infrastructure,
because the need is there,
it's recognized a lot of projects that
have already been prepared.
The government is,
for example,
a organizing mega power projects in
which all the preliminary work will have
been done by government of India itself
and by the state government.
So as soon as you go in,
you can start putting up the power plant
and we are an energy short country.
We are short of a lot of power.
And in order to sustain this kind of
regional growth infrastructure is going
to be the greatest challenge
for us.
That's one of the most interesting
phenomenon.
The
Indian entrepreneurship or you have of
course a lot of very highly recognizable
names of Indian origin entrepreneurs in
the United States itself.
Uh,
the head of Pepsi Co is an Indian woman
in the head of the new head of Citi
Group.
Uh,
Vikram Pandit is an Indian origin
person.
I'm the head of Roman Hoss,
which has just been bought up as you
know,
I was an Indian origin person,
Raj Gupta.
These are examples really of Indians who
have benefited from the fine American
education and have had the opportunity
but have grasped the opportunity to rise
on the Indian side.
Uh,
we have a number of groups which have
grown tremendously.
Daughters is possibly the most well
known,
but also in forces.
Wipro,
the powdered forge group,
Bobby Lloyd,
I'm this,
that in fact,
if you looked at India and you look at
the companies that are now our top 2015
of them didn't exist 15 years ago or 20
years ago.
So you can see that there's a lot of new
entrepreneurs and an interest.
Another interesting phenomenon is that
in the family owned businesses in India,
we now have the second generation who is
coming in to take over and run these
companies.
Most of them have had,
uh,
been to business schools in the United
States or in India and they are running
their business operations
nationally than was the case.